[Music]
[Applause]
Hello friends uh we are very thankful
that you decided to tune in today to
this question and answer program I'd
like to know uh you know as I travel uh
everywhere people tell us that this is
their favorite program that we do and
we've talked about the possibility of uh
possibility of extending it to an hour
rather than a half an hour each week but
we have so much production going on that
we haven't been able to do that but keep
sending your questions we might not
answer them immediately because we have
many many of them and we put them in
order but uh keep sending them let me
give you the electronic address it'll be
on the screen TV at
tv.org once again TVM
tv.org we'd be delighted to get your
questions uh you know we don't do this
uh question and answer program live and
there's a special reason why um we need
time to uh actually digest the question
we need to do research to make sure that
we give a full and complete answer to
the question you know when people call
in and you do it live you kind of uh
answer off the top of your head but uh
we want to do the research and we want
to answer uh fully and completely based
on Research I have with me Pastor David
Salasar good friend U fellow worker here
at Secrets unsealed uh in charge of uh
our Spanish work he's the CEO of U some
TV Latino and um we're glad to have you
thank you Pastor bour always a blessing
and a pleasure to be working with you we
always want to have a word of prayer
before we begin so could you pray for us
please
absolutely Heavenly Father we thank you
a once again for giving us the
opportunity to come to you in prayer to
understand that it is not our own
understanding or our own power that can
give answers to the questions that your
people have sent but is only through the
power of the Holy Spirit through your
influence in our minds in our hearts
that we can give answers that will help
them understand and see the light for
themselves so we pray Lord that you will
give us a portion of your Holy Spirit
today so we may understand and explain
and share the right words and the words
that will bring them to you and I pray
all of these in Jesus name amen amen
okay what do we have on the docket today
to start out with we have a very good
question from uh lady meldy we don't
know where she's sending us a question
from but uh I like her question and it's
a question that required for her to go
over some verses in the Bible she
actually said says the question I just
memorized Exodus 20
1-17 and she says uh why is the wife not
mentioned in verse 9 on the list that
should not work she obviously read verse
n of Revelation I mean Exodus 20 where
it speaks of the Sabbath but it says it
is it because she is the one heating the
food and working in the kitchen I'm
assuming she's uh you know uh perhaps a
wife and she's identifies maybe with
that experience of herself so is it
because the Bible in verse n where it
speaks about who should not work it
mentions your your manservant your maid
servant not your son or your daughter so
he mentions a few individuals but is not
does not mention the wife is it because
as she mentioned maybe she's the one
heating the food and working in the
kitchen so it's a good in question and I
want to you know we want to answer from
the word of God why is it Pastor Bor uh
well the bottom line is that um in the
Bible the man is the head of the
household and he's supposed to supervise
as the head his household and make sure
that his household abides by the rules
that God has
established and and so the wife would be
included in the husband because she's
one flesh with the man she was taken
from the man according to the AR
argument that the Apostle Paul uses and
so um the wife would definitely be
included in the council right through uh
the person of her husband it's important
that you know even from in in Genesis at
the very beginning in Genesis chapter
when well Adam and EV you made created
we can actually see that chapter uh one
also chapter two it it mentions there
you know that uh God gave the command to
Adam actually in chapter two right it
mentions there that
before it was made you know the Lord
told Adam what tree he should not eat of
he could eat the very one except the
tree of the knowledge of Good and Evil
so Genesis chapter 2 and verse 15 and 16
right 15 16 correct that's is where he
speaks to him and then after he sees the
need of Adam needing a part partner a
companion and he goes you know into the
Sleep the Lord gives and creates Eve
from his um you know rib his side he
actually then you know expects God
expects Adam to share and to be
responsible to express the knowledge of
the ordinance and the Commandment to his
wife so even in the very beginning of
Genesis or the beginning of mankind we
see this concept that by God creating
Adam
and then Eve he expects the men to have
that role of spiritual leadership
guidance and to really be the one that
teaches and holds his household
accountable before the Lord the head of
household correct is what we call it yes
exactly and you know the evidence of
this uh uh piggybacking on what you just
mentioned from The Book of Genesis right
um you know God does not hold Eve
accountable for the interest of sin into
the world although she sinned right
personally she's guilty because she
sinned right but God does not hold her
accountable for the introduction of sin
into the world right he holds Adam
accountable MH uh he comes to the Garden
after Adam and Eve have eaten from the
tree and uh it says in uh verse 11 mhm
uh to Adam and he said who told you that
you were
naked have you eaten from the Tree of
which I commanded you that you you
should not eat mhm Eve uh was under the
tutelage of
Adam and Adam was to was to uh look for
her welfare yeah but you know according
to the testimony of Ellen White Adam W
was guilty because he allowed Eve to
stray from his side when he should have
you know if he had been at the tree yeah
uh men are wired differently than women
they're more rational right women are
guided more by emotions
generally speaking and if Adam had been
with her probably uh sin would not have
come in yeah um God held Adam
accountable for the entrance of sin yes
he says through one man the Apostle Paul
says through one man sin came into the
world but Eve was the one who sinned
first right so the husband is supposed
to put an umbrella of protection upon
his wife in love for his wife and uh and
so uh when it says in the Commandment it
doesn't mention the wife the wife is
included right because she's one flesh
with the husband absolutely and that's
why it's called Adam they were one flesh
you know they were they were together as
one so it it is important so I think
that this is not that the Lord considers
the wife you know um of any type of
lesser or not worthy to be mentioned
it's just that he by mentioning the
Commandment to the house to the man to
the house to the head of household he is
implying that he needs to direct and
guide that household and of course
protect his wife and teach the the
Commandments to the people now it's a
last part of the question is it because
she's the one heating the food and
working in the kitchen is that consider
necessarily a work to be you know uh
breaking the law I know that it was not
allowed to collect wood on the Sabbath
they were not allowed to uh go out in
the fields and grab wood and you know to
be able to burn the things but I do
believe that they were allowed to Kindle
some wood for for warmth and so it's not
necessarily that that specifically is an
act of work is it Ellen White does
mention that meals should be prepared on
Friday MH um but we need to take into
account the time and place Ellen White
says we're supposed to take uh into
account time and place when it comes to
the testimonies uh what was it like to
cook meals yeah in the times of el
cooking meal is different story they did
not they did not have stoves gas or
electric stoves like we do today uh you
know they had to gather the wood and
then they had to light uh the fire and
uh you know it was just a very
complicated process it's kind of like
Ellen White states that we should not
take a bath on
Sabbath actually she doesn't say it that
way she says that all baths should be
taken on Friday before the beginning of
the Sabbath MH is she really saying that
we should not take a bath on Sabbath
well we need to understand how taking
baths were like in the times of ell and
white it was work you know it was there
they didn't have showers you know they
had to especially in the winter they had
to heat the water or they would freeze
to death right it was just a long
tedious process that would distract from
the observance of the Sabbath but you
know I once uh went to a Master guide
camper and there was this beautiful
Crystal Clear river that ran through uh
through the uh
campsite and it was hot and the master
guides had their khaki uniforms on on
Sabbath and there was this beautiful
Crystal Clear River cool water coming
from the mountains and one of the master
guides comes and says Pastor bore do you
think that we could actually maybe sit
in the water and cool
off um I didn't say what going swimming
on Sabbath you can't do that you know
suffer people are not supposed to suffer
on Sabbath so what I said is you know if
you uh Master guides sit in the water
talk of spiritual things just to cool
off that's fine right if I see you
splashing water and playing around
you're out of there of course and they
sat in the water and they talked about
spiritual things and you know talked
about the Bible and so on I don't think
I was wrong they they weren't taking a
bath on Sabbath they weren't going
swimming on Sabbath they were cooling
off on Sabbath and so we need to be we
need to not be fanatical MH and make
Sabbath a burden right you know there we
are to alleviate suffering on the
Sabbath in other words um but when it
comes to cooking in biblical times I'm
not sure that they had to follow all of
the process of cooking on S of course uh
you know they had the Mana which was a
vers very versatile food right uh that
they could be used it could be used in
many different ways and and this is one
you know the things that today maybe a
some people may feel that they couldn't
heat the food but you know she mentions
heating the food and you know if they're
heating the food that's not a
necessarily a mistake because it's so
simple today you know just turn on your
stove and for a few minutes and warm up
the food now cooking preparing making
the meal that's a different story and
that is of course what should not be
done in the Sabbath as we don't want to
take time you know working on the
kitchen just for the sake of making food
so I I think it's very important to
follow the councel but not like you said
be fanatical or go to the point of you
have to eat just cold you know food for
for the sake of not even turning on the
kitchen or the the stove yeah uh God
doesn't want us to eat cold food on the
Sabbath that that should be heated right
uh we need to be practical in other
words and uh you know our kids are
involved you know sometimes our kids are
turned off on Sabbath observance yes
because we make it a day of restrictions
and prohibitions and we don't emphasize
the blessing of the Sabbath and what
what can be done on the Sabbath so we
need to make the Sabbath a delight like
it says in the book of Isaiah praise the
Lord amen well all right we have another
question and this one comes from
Charlene and uh I wish Charlene would
let us know where she's from but we
don't know that yet but it says this my
question concerns the parallel you drew
between the small cloud in the Elijah
story and the small Cloud that appears
when Jesus is on his way back I always
thought that it was the sign that the
rain was on its way to end a threeyear
drought I suppose it may be a little of
both however the area I would like you
to address in particular is this if the
cloud was The Chariot of angels coming
to scoop up Elijah it seemed to me that
it was a long time coming since the
prophet had had time to run ahead of the
king's Chariot hide from the queen visit
the school of prophets and take a
protected stroll with his rep
replacement Elisha based on your
understanding how long a period of time
was it from The Showdown of the Mountain
to the Rival of The Chariot of Israel
and the horsemen thereof thanks so much
for the Insight you provide Charlene and
this is probably for a ceron you made
the the emphasis was not on the time
interval between uh uh Elijah seeing the
cloud and all the other things that are
mentioned in the question yeah the
parallel is on the cloud itself uh not
the period of time between seeing the
cloud and when actually Elijah is taken
to heaven in The Chariot um that's
that's the reason why I mentioned the
cloud and Ellen White does mention uh as
well as the gospel of Matthew that the
sign of the son of man is the
cloud that in the distance is seen like
half the palm of the man's hand very
small and she does say that that is
God's Chariot because then it moves
closer to the Earth and she says that it
becomes a white cloud of course of the
clouds of angels uh so um I see the
parallel being in the cloud not in the
time interval between uh the scene of
the cloud and when Elijah is actually
translated to heaven right you're not
you're not implying that the cloud
started moving at that moment is and
coming in the same time frame as god's
second coming will be you know is just a
symbol that the Lord showed Elijah to
remind him or let him know what that
coming or what symbol was off yeah and
uh you know we're dealing with a story
MH we're not dealing with with with
typology we're not dealing with uh in
other words you're not applying the de
day principle to to this particular
historical situation um historical
prophecies you do apply the time period
uh in prophetic uh prophecies you apply
the Year Day principle it's a longer
period of time so uh you know the
parallel is between uh between the cloud
and the taking away it to heaven and The
Chariot amen
well I'm thankful that our readers and
our you know our friends can watch and
asking us questions of that the next
question Pastor Bor comes from Thompson
and he uh ask the following question how
does God Harden someone's heart how is
the heart
hardened H what do it mean or what does
it mean for God to harden the heart
these questions are structured from
Exodus 14 where God said I will harden
Fair heart I think Pastor you have
explained this but let's give an an
explanation today to Thompson okay um I
like to give an
illustration and that is that um The Sun
Shines on the clay and hardens it the
same Sun Shines on the ice and melts
it so it's not the sun's
fault that the clay is hardened and the
ice is melted it's the consistency of
the thing that it shines on right and so
in the case of pharaoh uh you know God
shined his light on them the plagues and
you know Moses and Aaron going and
speaking to him and everything I mean
what more light could he have and yet
what did the light do like the clay it
hardened it his hard what was God's
intention oh that that it's soften the
heart they get the light and they
receive the truth in the
Bible uh what God
allows is attributed to him yeah so God
allowed his heart to be hardened it was
Pharaoh's choice but God was not really
the one who was hardening the heart he
was shining the light and Pharaoh
hardened his heart and by the way in
those first chapters of Exodus there are
many verses that say that Pharaoh
hardened his heart there are some verses
that say that that God hardened his
heart other places say that Pharaoh
hardened his heart it kind of reminds me
of um of when Saul was possessed by
demons that's right it says that that an
evil spirit from the Lord came and
tormented Saul well God doesn't go
around sending tormenting spirits to
people what it means is because of
Saul's choices in
Disobedience God said you don't want me
God withdrew and he allowed the evil
spirits to take possession of Saul so uh
it's a it's a parallel type of situation
you know another example is in 2
Thessalonians 2 where it says that uh
God will send strong delusion to them
well God doesn't go around deluding
people of course you know what it means
is that God allows Satan to delude them
because and it says clearly because they
rejected the love of the truth uh so I
think that's the way that we need to
understand the hardening of Pharaoh's
heart it God shines upon pharaoh he
hardens his heart and what God allows in
the Bible is attributed to him and
ultimately this is the type of
experience where someone can come or can
become guilty of the unpardonable sin
you know they have hardened their heart
so much that uh as they are receiving
the light instead of yielding to that
light to that truth they choose to
reject the light and makes it harder and
harder for the Holy Spirit to the point
that no longer can contend with that
person's
heart uh we have a we have an example of
this uh in the Book of Job first two
chapters who is it that's is causing all
the problems for job Satan it's clearly
it's Satan yeah of course but but uh God
is allowing it right yes now the
interesting thing is when you get to the
end of the book in chapter 42 it speaks
about all the evil that the Lord brought
upon job so so when you take these two
texts together you see that you God
brought all this evil upon job because
he allowed it yeah not because he caused
it and that's kind of important to keep
in mind now is is got responsible for
for the for the mishappening to job or
to the individuals he's not the one
responsible is their own choice by not
yielding to that light and to that
influence of God that they Harden their
hearts and they reject now in the case
of job of course it's a little different
because the Lord allows him to be tried
and in that sense he allows the trial to
prove the character of job and his
Fidelity his faithfulness to him and
that is something that also the Lord
will allow for the sake of even for our
own experience to understand more who
Christ and what Christ did for us so
it's it's important to keep that in mind
as well yeah by the way is if somebody's
interested in the text where God uh
brings this evil upon job yeah it's in
chapter 42 the last chapter of job verse
11 says then all his brothers and all
his sisters and those who had been his
acquaintances before came to him and ate
food with him in his house and they
consoled him and comforted him for all
the adversity that the Lord had brought
upon him so uh so you know when you have
these two verses in the same book yeah
where Satan is actively doing it but the
Lord brought it upon him we understand
that it's God's permissive will God has
a causitive will yeah where he causes
things but at the same time God has a
permissive will where he allows certain
things to happen depending on the
circumstances now Pastor could it be
also important to uh remember that
ultimately God is absolutely in control
of all things and he allows things and
in his
infinite understanding and wisdom he
will only grant us what we can handle he
will not give us or allow a test beyond
our experience beyond our our our
ability in the power of Christ to
overcome or to keep and continue in the
faith uh by by you know holding on to
Christ Christ so I believe that we have
to keep that in mind that you know the
test and the trials that can be given or
Allowed by the Lord will not be without
an a door an opening for us to sustain
and to survive them with the power of
God there's actually a Bible verse that
says that yeah exactly 1 Corinthians
chapter 10 and verse 13 says no
temptation by the way the word
temptation can be translated test or
trial right uh there is no temptation
has overtaken you if except such as is
common to man mhm but God is faithful
who will not allow you to be tempted or
tried or tested beyond what you are able
right but with the Temptation or the
trial or the test will also make the
weight of Escape amen that you may be
able to Bear it so that's God's promise
that uh he will give a way of escape
with it if we depend upon him and this
is important so that we are not going to
be you know falling into this false
concept or idea that God can you know
send us something that is harmful just
because he wants that is only when he
sees that it will benefit us in our
experience of growth in Transforming Our
character or or our hearts more like him
that he allows the trials to be given to
purify our hearts to purify purifies as
gold yeah it's uh it's God's discipline
mhm you know it's to make us it's not to
break us uh you
know Satan tests us because he wants to
break us right he wants to break our
alliance to the Lord but the Lord
knowing our hearts allows trials to come
so that we are like uh gold in the
furnace of fire could God have delivered
the three young men before they were
thrown out into the fire could delivered
Daniel without him having to go into the
lion's den of course he could have but
this strengthened yeah the determination
and the faith and the trust of Daniel
and his friends in the Lord amen and so
once again the trials are meant to
strengthen our faith they are not meant
to weaken our faith amen amen well folks
um it's been nice having you watch our
program today may the Lord bless you and
keep you hope to see you at our next
program and I'd like to know
[Music]